[Music]
this is fried mac and cheese everything
about this is just Wow what's up guys
I'm cute and today I'm gonna be trying
to send McDonald's for the US somebody
down from Tokyo and see how they rank up
against each other I know I make
donald's in the u.s. taste and I'm
interested to see what they got going on
in Japan so you should be interested in
a variety where do we start
sausage made griddle classic I love Nick
giggles this is probably my favorite
thing to get from McDonald's it's
amazing well it's base look like a
sausage biscuit what with pancake buns
I'm a person who loves cake I like
sweets this is the perfect blend of
sweet and savory and you really can't
beat it
hmm this is good tough like Tokyo has to
have this cuz it's so good but then
again I wouldn't be surprised if they
don't I feel like this is also like a
super American thing to like make it so
unhealthy like the outside it has like
CERP the bun is a little start beep if
you order something from McDonald's for
breakfast and it's not a McGriddle
that's the Bell
all right I'm officially in Tokyo
actually in my pop it's all right now so
I can't be too loud it's like a ASMR I
can cheeseburger kind of breakfast
this kind of surprise behind this in the
US I mean obviously you literally just
order this is the sausage egg and cheese
McMuffin personally I'm not a huge fan
of the sausage egg and cheese McMuffin
it does look great this looks amazing
but let's be honest it looks really good
I think at one point in my life when I
was kind of eating too many McGriddle
this was my next option you know I'm Zen
and it was a good like two months of my
life but this cheese on here to expire
though I'll say that the reason why I'm
not a big fan even though it does taste
good is just dry like it's like a dry
sandwich
somebody got choke on this go in there
I'm telling you it's not really my thing
but like it's okay yeah I feel like
Tokyo will have more to offer than this
I hope so this is the teriyaki burger
excuse me teriyaki burger you this moto
teriyaki is strong it's pretty good I
feel like if you like the barbecue
burgers you probably like something like
this but it's a lot of sauce like it's a
interesting taste what the lettuce
oh I think the port-to-port look at this
this is a sign of good fries you see how
they're just sticking up they're
pointing up like hair or something like
just straight up in there
that's a crispy fry now they was soggy
and like leaning over so you know have a
little wiggle room you know this is good
McDonald's fries arguably the best
bachelor fried like what is better than
McDonald's fries anybody nothing nothing
I've no doubt in my mind that these are
gonna be the Tokyo fries so I guess not
even a question
yeah a little soggy a little soggy but
they're good funny enough and contests
like Burger King fries I need to talk to
my manager that looks delicious
please oh my goodness everything about
this is just Wow okay so you know when
you go to me down with your friends
anywhere you're like my food isn't gonna
look like it does on the menu and the
advertisement this right here this is
damn near it I mean II was a little bit
spinning machines we got one of those
know how budget hmm
this is really good I never had one any
before but this is fire this seems to be
the perfect amount of everything not too
much meat it's not too much cheese this
is fire I don't know how to Tokyo
burgers are gonna rank up to this but I
guess a little sneak so this is fried
mac and cheese and there's beef on top
of here they're really lucky but it
should be pretty tasty
so chewy that's pretty good
super soft really tasty the sauce on top
it's like a beef sauce it looks kind of
weird but overall it's pretty good this
is a shrimp flavor here it's put
together very poorly but it's probably
good don't give out napkin that's crazy
that's definitely a striker chance Tokyo
u.s. they'll give you a whole box they
put your burger that is whole box
there's a really good if I'm go with
this or a fish fillet this one every day
not even a question
it's not a very fishy taste you there
also has I have a sauce kind of tastes
like make sauce this might be the best
thing guys so far okay one thing that
you can't get wrong at McDonald's is a
box of chicken nuggets you get the right
sauce these are amazing I personally
like either getting honey
or maybe like barbecue sauce or honey
mustard or something like that these are
good like they're nice and like golden
brown like that's how you notice ain't
good for you because they all look the
same you know I'm saying like they
should all have like a different shape
and size and look yeah think about that
I don't know word of sauce is that yes
so like these were like hot mustard
sauce amazing you know it's good to do
go to Burger King and order some
McNugget uh you wanna get somebody man
do that last but not least
I mean that's your average Big Mac but I
like it
my brother you still wear decent worried
under all the time you know I always
look at him like but not look at me
overseas eating him up happy no I
legitimately haven't seen or up one of
these in like a decade this is gonna be
interesting
oh boy comes in here let me see what
Twitter's alright that's pretty that's
pretty cute what the hell that's pretty
cute okay here we go
I don't know what this does what is this
I don't know cool it's cute they kept it
nice and simple for those picky kids
just put some meat and some ketchup
the hell it need that's all they want is
it bring me back
I thought the three-year-old surprise oh
I will say the kiddie fries aren't as
good hasn't grown people fries something
different going on in the water a gogurt
I'm excited honestly it's cute but taste
wise no just go-gurt might be great
though this might be the game changer
class I'll get a happy one just for a
goal there ain't a toy and I mean that
wholeheartedly I still don't know what
the hell this time for dessert Oh double
chuckle melts
diesel like this Cosby brownies with
like chocolate fudge on top not at all
I know what the hell this is but no Jim
Berry - apple pie stop playing for me o
thoughtful are we talking about some
Tokyo stuff right here this is fire this
is the best dessert
mcDonald's has period all right so that
does it live from my pocket so we have
to compared to u.s. versus Tokyo even
mcdonnell's and in this instance I'm
gonna have to say us one like I'm sure
isn't in this because it's familiar
desserts is better burgers are better
overall they'll have to give it to us on
his own but that pink dang this was fire
[Music]